Чарівний пейзаж Верховини у Карпатах.
У цих краях на Заході України глибоко вкоренилася
в людську природу віра в магічні сили.
Це Магдалена Мочіовські.
Її називають мольфаркою. Магдалена стверджує,
що володіє прадавніми таємничими знаннями.
Мольфарами не стають, мольфарами народжуються.
Тільки в дуже індивідуальних випадках
може людина стати мольфаром.
Тому що мольфарство це є сакральне знання,
яке передається з покоління в покоління.
З давніх-давен в цьому карпатському регіоні
жили віруючі люди. Тут на 30 тисяч
осіб - 40 церков. Але релігійним
населення було ще до того, як прийшло християнство.
Магдалена показує своє знаряддя:
маятник з нитки і цвяха,
тупий ніж, трави.
За її словами, за допомогою цих предметів
можна ворожити і зцілювати людей.
Для того, щоб зазирнути у майбутнє,
треба розкинути кістки Карпатського зайця.
Також кістки захистять, щоб не наврочили.
Відьму визначають,
дивлячись через кістку зайця.
Тут язичництво переплелося із християнством.
Мольфари використовують під час ворожінь
і християнські символи. Їхні молитви
змішані зі стародавніми заклинаннями.
Мольфар Довбуш зустрічає Павлу.
Щось в неї не складаються стосунки із сусідкою.
Хто мій друг, хто мій ворог, ти мя покажи.
Ви щось відчуваєте у долоні?
Ну, тепло трошки... - Тепло відчуваєте.
У вас є дуже хороша подруга...
...яка завидує...
Потім Павла має кинути монетку на узбіччя -
так зване мито для демонів,
щоб вони відступили.
Для завершення ритуалу жінка повертається до мольфара.
Гори, згорай, моя чорная біль,
моя порча, згорай,
хазяйку свою не забувай, до неї повертай.
Мучай її, карай, пощади ні вдень, ні вночі не давай.
Ну, що ви чуєте? - Чую полегкість
якусь таку, якби зняла з себе якийсь тягар.
Да буде так, амінь.
Віруваннями і забобонами просякнуті Карпати.
Останніми роками мольфари ворожать
і на перемогу України у війні на Сході.
Як дим відходить від вогню. хай так
і ворог відійде від нашого кордону віднині і повік.
Однак, на жаль, поки ні магія,
ні чаклунство не подіяли.